so I'm superintendent Mark tarbert and
I'm the police Commander for Milton
Keynes I'm really saddened to be talking
to you under such tragic circumstances
today
so I'll run through the facts as we
currently know them and then I'll
provide some updates
so just after 5 p.m yesterday afternoon
officers were called to a property in
Broadlands in netherfield where it's
reported that the child had been
attacked by a dog in a back Garden
medical staff attended the location but
sadly a four-year-old girl was
pronounced dead at the scene
formal identification has not yet taken
place
and our thoughts are with our family and
friends at this difficult time
the child's family are being supported
by specially trained officers and we'd
ask that their privacy is respected
an investigation is currently underway
to fully understand the circumstances
that we currently believe that this was
a tragic isolated incident and there is
no threat to the wider community
accordingly no arrests have been made at
this time
I can confirm that the dog was a family
pet and was put down by police at the
scene yesterday evening
and part of the investigation is to
establish the breed of that dog
while our investigation takes place
there will be more offices in the area
over the coming days
this is clearly an incident that has
shocked and upset upset people
and I urge residents to speak to offices
with any questions or concerns they may
have
I'd also like to ask the community for
their support in not speculating about
this matter
and offer reassurance that our
detectives are working hard to progress
the investigation and you can contact us
if you have any information
I'll share further updates when we have
them
and thank you